Warren is next in Minnesota hi Corrin
how are you hello Dave and dr. Dee thank
you for taking my call it's an honor to
speak with you today you too thank you
so I have a question for you so I am the
spender in the relationship and I want
to work on changing this habit of
spending my feelings of like grief and
guilt and shame and I would like to know
how I can do that successfully
so having gone through severe grief and
sadness in the past I was suffering the
loss of seven pregnancies within six
years
I found myself spending money that I
felt I like dessert to spend with that
you know to help with that suffering or
so I saw it and so now we paid off a
hundred thousand dollars in debt in the
last ten months and a lot of that was
credit card debt due to myself so moving
forward when we're debt-free next March
I don't want to repeat the same habit so
I want to whether those emotional storms
and I want to be able to you know come
up with better solutions to how I spend
and so as hoping that you could help me
with that today wow that's a lot of loss
in six years just a lot of loss yeah
it's devastating gone through it so have
you have you mourn the loss of each one
of these young lives
uh-huh you know I eat sometimes they
were you know further apart so gave me
time sometimes it was compounded within
a month or two of each other we had
seven failed you know fertility
treatments within that as well and so I
think that compounded grief didn't I was
trying to survive it's you know every
day so as time has gone on it's been
better to be able to grieve so what I
normally tell folks who are what I call
have a transfer behavior they have
trauma they've got lost they've got
heaviness which loss of pregnancies
our we've I've experienced this in my
own house they're devastating in a way
that because there's that silence and
there's that shame and there's that as
my body work and there's husband and
wives agree with this differently and it
just creates communication chaos all
that right when people didn't move to
behaviors that that just to distract us
right whether that's spending I would
even call and hope this doesn't sound
sack religion in in this show there's a
chance that you can transfer identity
from I'm gonna be a mom to loss to the
baby steps right and at some point
you've got a transfer trust back to your
relationship with your husband
you got a transfer trust back to
yourself and that starts with truly
grieving what has happened and seven
losses of seven seven pregnancy losses
in six years I don't know anybody that
can do that by themselves and so I'd
recommend you get a counselor get a
professional get a pastor that you trust
and do this with your husband and
mmm-hmm
truly grieve the losses of each one of
these pregnancies and then set up a
system for yourself coming out of this
that makes it very difficult for you to
default to your spending habit in my
life I gave my debit card to my wife for
a season I'd unhook Amazon Prime for a
season but I had to make it hard for
myself until I developed these other
behaviors that were gonna be toward
something and not just in response to
trying to cover up trauma but it starts
with truly truly grieving the losses
there yeah the I think John's exactly
right as you go through that part of it
and you get some somebody walking with
you in that part and guiding you then
you do put the systems in place and it
can be you know and I think the way you
honestly yourself awareness that you
just said this all out loud no one had
to figure it out you've already figured
it out you went I overspent
I was medicating my hurt you know and it
brought us hundred thousand dollars in
debt I got shamed from that now we
cleaned that debt up
and I never want to go back I mean all
of the fact that you can put all of that
in about three or four sentences
indicates you're in a really good place
way ahead of the curve yeah because I
mean I wanted to pull all of that out of
you you laid it all out and just you
know which means you've already
processed it and your self-awareness is
a you know recognizing there is a
problem as 90% of solving one you know
and you really are there so then I yeah
I would make sure you guys are doing a
budget and that there are no secret
accounts and that every month any
spending that he does any spending that
you do both of you would know about it
mmm-hmm because the only way you did
this crap was in secret that's right
yeah I last August when I found you Dave
I went to my husband you said two things
on that first call I listened to he said
get on the same page with your spouse
and stop the bleeding and I went home
that day and we changed like 180 we
changed our entire financial world yeah
I'm proud of you've done it right John
if you guys are working the budget
together and you are committed to your
in a contract with your spouse that
neither one of you spend money that the
other one doesn't know about and it all
shows up on the budget which by the way
David inserting Ramsey do that to this
day and John and John the Loney and
Sheila do that to this day they do a
budget every month we stick to the
budget we don't spend money that's not
on the budget we don't have any side
deals this is it and you know then that
that's the accountability if that's not
enough accountability then you may have
to unplug from a couple of things and
lean in lean against your husband to
carry you through a couple of those
things like John said he turned over his
debit card he he he unplugged and leaned
over and you can do that too if you need
to but I don't know if you're gonna need
to I you know I think you got some grief
work to do that John suggested and
prescribed and you got that from the
doctor here so you do need to follow
that prescription and then from from my
perspective if you'll keep doing what
you've been doing since you
has worked on the same page and you
don't have any side deals then I think
you're gonna be pretty safe
given how self-aware you are yeah but
it's not unusual at all to have someone
with a loss spending is a socially
acceptable drug yeah it's it's harder to
get off of then cocaine right you don't
cocaine downstairs some people crawl in
the bottle that's not a socially
acceptable you know some people crawl
into other stuff it's not you can't talk
about that it's theirs but spending is
like I just spend some money what's the
big deal but you could kind of
rationalize it in your head a lot more
and the number of people that medicate
grief was spending we warn for instance
widows in the loss of a husband our
husbands and loss of a wife would worse
the same thing be very very careful with
that because the number of times I have
met with somebody two years after the
loss and they burned through 400 grand
worth of life insurance and all that was
was grief spending that's right it's
medication and medicated spending and
that that'll burn some money it'll burn
some money seriously and you can't
outrun tragedy you can't outrun grief it
hangs on you and it hangs on you you
just got to do the hard work and turn
around and face it